>>> I ALWAYS GOT THE SENSE THAT
MATT LOOKED DOWN ON ME, BUT
THAT'S ONLY 'CAUSE HE'S TWO
INCHES TALLER.
[ LAUGHTER ]
NO, BUT I'M SO HAPPY FOR YOU,
BUDDY, I LOVE YOU, BRO.
TO MATT AND TANYA, CHEERS!
>> OKAY.
YES, HOW ABOUT A HAND FOR MATT'S
BEST MAN, NATE!
ALL RIGHT!
[ APPLAUSE ]
YAY.
I'M SO SORRY I'M CHEWING, THAT
WAS JUST AN INCREDIBLY SHORT
SPEECH.
IT OPENED WITH THAT "LOOKED DOWN
ON ME" JOKE, AND, IT JUST KIND
OF ENDED A FEW SENTENCES LATER.
SO I WAS SURE IT WOULD BE
LONGER, WHICH IS WHY I TOOK A
BITE OF FOOD, BUT I WAS WRONG.
BUT STILL, A VERY NICE SPEECH
FROM NATE.
OKAY.
NOW LET'S HEAR FROM THE MAID OF
HONOR.
IT'S TANYA'S BEST FRIEND, SARAH,
COME ON UP, SARAH!
>> YEAH!
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> HI, EVERYONE.
I'M SARAH.
UM, MATT, LET ME JUST TELL YOU
SOMETHING.
YOU'RE A REALLY LUCKY GUY.
BECAUSE TANYA IS THE BEST GIRL
IN THE WORLD.
>> AW.
>> I MEAN, THIS GIRL IS LIKE --
>> YES, SHE IS.
>> SHE'S LIKE A SISTER TO ME.
AND NOT JUST BECAUSE WE'VE BOTH
SEEN MY DAD NAKED.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> OKAY.
>> SHE'S ALWAYS HAD MY BACK.
EVEN WHEN NOBODY ELSE AGREED
WITH ME, SHE ALWAYS SAID,
"SARAH, IF YOU SAY YOU'RE SOBER
ENOUGH TO DRIVE THEN I BELIEVE
YOU."
AND THAT MEANT THE WORLD TO ME,
GIRLIE.
AND WHEN I STUMBLE, WHEN I MAKE
A MISTAKE, SHE'D NEVER MAKE ME
FEEL BAD.
SHE'D SAY, "GIRLIE, DON'T BEAT
YOURSELF UP, NOBODY KNEW THAT
THING WAS LOADED."
>> DID SHE SHOOT SOMEONE?
>> BABE, I'M TRYING TO LISTEN.
>> AND WHEN SHE'S GOING THROUGH
A TOUGH TIME HERSELF, SHE
DOESN'T COMPLAIN, SHE DANCES.
PROFESSIONALLY.
>> WHAT KIND OF DANCING?
>> BABE?
>> LIKE, SHE'S NOT PERFECT.
>> NO WAY.
>> WHAT KIND OF DANCING?
>> SHE HAS BEEN A BIT OF A
BRIDEZILLA, AND NOT JUST BECAUSE
SHE ATTACKED A LOT OF JAPANESE
PEOPLE.
I AM IN AWE OF HER.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT ALL OF YOU,
BUT IF MY LAST 15 BOYFRIENDS
KILLED THEMSELVES, I'D GIVE UP
ON ROMANCE.
BUT NOT TANYA.
>> SHE'S -- SHE'S JOKING, RIGHT?
>> 'CAUSE SHE BELIEVES IN LOVE.
WHEN I STARTED DATING MY
NOW-HUSBAND, SHE WAS SO HAPPY
FOR ME.
EVERYONE ELSE SAID, "YOU'RE A
MONSTER."
BUT WHAT DID YOU SAY, GIRLIE?
>> "YOU'RE NOT A MONSTER, YOU'RE
JUST HIS MATH TEACHER."
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
LOVE IS LOVE, RIGHT, BABY?
>> NO DOUBT.
>> BUT MOST OF ALL, TANYA IS
BRAVE.
GIRLIE, I KNOW YOU REMEMBER
THIS.
WE WERE AT A PROTEST FIGHTING
FOR JUSTICE.
AND YOU GOT RIGHT IN THAT COP'S
FACE.
NO FEAR AT ALL.
AND DO YOU REMEMBER WHAT YOU
SAID?
>> "I'M STORMING THE CAPITOL AND
I'M GOING TO KILL MIKE PENCE."
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
AND MATT, YOU MAKE HER SO HAPPY.
I DON'T WANT TO EMBARRASS YOU,
BUT WHEN YOU GUYS FIRST GOT
TOGETHER, ME AND TONIA ARE
HAVING SOME GIRL TALK AND I
SAID, YOU KNOW, "HOW'S THE
CHEMISTRY IN THE BEDROOM?"
>> HA, NO, HERE WE GO.
>> AND SHE SAID, "HE'S TRYING
HIS BEST."
AND THAT'S WHAT MAKES MATT
DIFFERENT FROM THE HUNDREDS AND
HUNDREDS OF OTHER GUYS THAT
SHE'S DRAGGED HOME OVER THE
YEARS.
>> HUNDREDS?
>> BABY.
>> AND SURE, MAYBE HE'S NOT
FAMOUS LIKE STEVE-O FROM
"JACKASS," OR "WEE MAN" FROM
"JACKASS."
MAYBE HE'S NOT MYSTERIOUS, LIKE
BAM MARGERA FROM "JACKASS."
BUT HE PUT IN THE WORK.
LIKE JOHNNY KNOXVILLE, FROM
"JACKASS."
>> SO YOU JUST GOT WITH THE
WHOLE "JACKASS" GANG, THEN?
>> HEY HONEY.
I LISTENED TO YOUR FRIEND'S
SPEECH, OKAY?
COME ON.
>> SHE LOVED YOU RIGHT AWAY,
MATT.
AFTER YOUR FIRST DATE SHE SAID,
"I MET MY PERSON," AND SHE
DELETED ALL THE DATING APPS.
MATCH, TINDER, CHOKE PONY, TOR
DARK WEB BROWSER, ALL OF THEM.
AT LEAST, I THINK SHE DID.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> YES, I DID, YOU CAN CHECK MY
PHONE.
>> WHY DO YOU HAVE THREE PHONES?
>> SO YEAH, SHE LOVES YOU, MATT.
AND I KNOW WHEN SHE'S FINALLY
ABLE TO GET HER KIDS BACK, THEY
WILL LOVE YOU TOO.
>> WHAT -- WHAT KIDS?
>> AND ALL THOSE KIDS' DADS ARE
GONNA RESPECT YOU.
>> WHAT KIDS AND WHAT DADS?
>> BECAUSE IT'S NOT EVERY MAN
WHO HAS THE COURAGE TO MARRY
SUGE KNIGHT'S EX.
BUT YOU DO, MATT.
YOU DO.
SO CONGRATS, BOTH OF YOU!
CHEERS!
>> CHEERS!
>> LOVE YOU, GIRLIE.
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> I'M GONNA DIE.